my job is to deal with the evidence in a
way it's my only job that's my job the
job is evidence the job is thinking
the job is ratiocination the job is
separating truth from untruth subject
unknown moves that is to say things that
you think you know
that it turns out you did not
hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and
today we're talking with Errol Morris
he's the oscar-winning filmmaker whose
great works include the Thin Blue Line
from 1988 mr. death 1999 fog of war
standard operating procedure tabloid
from 2010 and his new latest movie the
unknown known which is a long
fascinating conversation with Donald
Rumsfeld who was Secretary of Defense
and as such was directing our efforts
both in Afghanistan and Iraq for a good
chunk of the 21st century
Errol thanks for talking to us thank you
for having me on but I'm not sure what
I'm on well you know turnabout is fair
play right to use it in tera Tron
against the person who created it but
you you are in in the New York Times
you're writing a four-part series of
essays about Rumsfeld and about and
about the themes explored in the unknown
known and that title comes from a famous
kind of ditty that Rumsfeld gave early
in 2003 and it was about kind of
epistemology and of war and you write
that Rumsfeld to answer was a non answer
not just in an evasion or a misdirection
many believe it was brilliant
I think otherwise why do you think
otherwise for many many reasons
context of course is one of them people
of course forget about the context in
which he first presented these ideas to
the public the context 2002 were
planning a possible invasion of Iraq a
Pentagon reporter the NBC correspondent
Jim miklaszewski asks Donald Rumsfeld
what evidence do you have that Saddam
Hussein is providing terrorist
organizations with weapons of mass
destruction it's a very specific
question and it's a question about guess
why evidence right the e word
what evidence do you have Rumsfeld's
answer
there's the no known the known unknown
the unknown unknown another Pentagon
reporter says but that was not an answer
to Nicola Jeff's keys question
Rumsfeld says well evidence of absence
is an absence of evidence and so on and
so forth so we're in a total Alice in
Wonderland scenario here right where the
I mean there's a sense that Rumsfeld is
not only not going to answer but that he
is going to kind of toy with with
reporters or with um with the American
public as this this is the whole ball of
wax right if they're if Saddam Hussein
is not producing weapons of mass
destruction or consorting with
terrorists there's really no cause for
action that's correct so how did
rumsfeld get away with this type of
evasion which early in the in the you
know after early in afghanistan and
early in iraq his press conferences were
about the you know the biggest bit of
must-see TV on a regular basis why did
so many people seem to respond warmly to
the fact that the Secretary of Defense
as we were in one war and entering
another evaded questions left and right
you really want an answer I get up at
least a start of one we're all morons
mm-hmm you know how many people have
said to me over the years that no known
known unknown unknown unknown stuff
that's really brilliant this is to use
the big word heavy man yeah epistemology
philosophy blah blah blah blah blah
can I ask what you know for the New York
Times you did a series not too long ago
a series of short documentaries about
why people should vote if we're all
morons should we be voting why not okay
fair enough let me ask you you know the
Rumsfeld documentary
obvious I don't know I don't know why
people bought in to Rumsfeld
gobbledygook yes I wrote a series of
four-part series which is up as we speak
in the New York Times on these ideas
call it the philosophy if you like of
Donald Rumsfeld I changed the title at
the last minute I was a little
uncomfortable with the philosophy of
Donald Rumsfeld I changed it to the
certainty of Donald runs right I object
to the known known the known unknown for
a whole number of reasons one of course
is the context in which he said it which
was avoiding the question that he had
been asked by the Pentagon reporter and
a very very important question about the
nature of what evidence did he have to
support a war but I object to it on
another level the fact that it is
hopelessly vague
maybe it's my epiphany thinking about
this concatenation of words of the known
and the unknown that the important thing
for all of us is not the know known the
known unknown the important thing is
fact and fiction belief versus knowledge
I believe such-and-such is it a
nonsensical belief or is it a true
belief and how do I separate one from
the other how do I determine what is
real knowledge and that which is just
belief and I believe wholeheartedly but
the whole thrust of Rumsfeld so-called
philosophizing is the devaluation of
evidence instead of thinking about
evidence and what evidence me
what evidence is there and what evidence
isn't there what can be supported and
what can't be what claim makes sense and
what claim makes no sense he in stead
drifts often to some kind of crazy meta
talk that is seemingly significant but
is not does it mean we're all morons
means were all deeply gullible we're all
suggestible
we're uncritical at moments where we in
fact should be do you do you believe
then that you know one of the things
that is striking in the fog of war
Robert McNamara says you know you at a
press conference you never answer the
question that you're asked you answer
the question you want to answer and I
guess you would say that at least
McNamara answered questions whereas
Rumsfeld you know as you were said it's
it's not even an evasion it's not a
non-answer it's a total evasion do you
think Rumsfeld had the answer to
questions about weapons of mass
destruction and chose not to give them
because it would undercut his case or
does he actually exist in a world where
there is no ultimately no evidence only
belief only will you have addressed the
central question of the movie is what
the known and unknown or in this
instance the unknown known my movie is
all about it's all about that question
does he know and won't say does even
care to know one way or the other
is he a Salesman lost inside of his own
ability to sell to the point where he is
no longer reflective in any deep sense
about what he's saying I came to believe
at the end of this whole process that he
is a man who does not think clearly
about things often he has this amazing
capacity I find it amazing
he has a capacity to say
contradictory things seemingly without
even realizing that they're
contradictory there's a famous line in a
short story by F scott Fitzgerald a
crack-up
and he says that the sign of a
first-rate intelligence is the ability
to hold two opposing ideas in the mind
at the same time and I add in my essay
well it's the ability to hold two
opposing or contradictory ideas in the
mind at the same time and know that
they're contradictory you uh you know
one of the things that's fascinating
about the the movie is that Rumsfeld you
know writes the an endless stream of
memos that become known as snowflakes
throughout the movie because there's so
many there's just a constant kind of
blizzard of snow snowflakes being sent
out to people any fixates on the
definition or the way that you talk
about it is that he's obsessed with
getting the exact definition of words
which obviously plays into the way that
he handled the press and the media and
one assumes other countries he would
always fixate on the exact language like
a philosopher of language or a linguist
and by the end you had forgotten our the
idea is that you would forget what you
were talking about or what the stakes
were in the fog of war Robert McNamara
did the same thing with math in your you
know fantastic movie mr. death about
Fred and Luther Jr who repaired electric
chairs you see a man who is grappling
with the enormity of what he's doing for
his job and he becomes a Holocaust
denier and is there's this massive
search for evidence is there something
about the work that these three people
in your movies are in that forces them
to leave the planet that they live on
and only exists in a kind of astral
plane of fantasy so that they don't ever
have to confront themselves Luger is a
man who never has confronted himself and
most likely never will
Robert McNamara is different in that
respect he's a
and who actually has attempted to
confront his past when a man who lives I
believe in a world of regret Don
Rumsfeld far far more like Fred Luter
than like Robert McNamara I'm left with
this deep feeling of his disconnection
from reality he argued with me he didn't
like the scene in my movie that shows
his departure from the Pentagon well he
was fired he was shown the door by
george w bush literally shown the door
we see him getting a somewhat
condescending pat on the back in the
Oval Office and then being ushered out
the door
Rumsfeld didn't like the scene because
he said to me it made him look like he
had left the Pentagon in disgrace
well okay he wanted to see more of the
heraldic ceremonies he wanted to see the
in comb iums from Dick Cheney he wanted
to see the heraldry and regalia the
marching bands the braids the buttons
the medals and and me my selfishness my
stingy nasai had failed to include all
of it but I didn't change the film even
though I knew that he didn't like it he
didn't like that scene in it in
particular perhaps we just differ but I
think there are a lot of people who
would agree with me
he left the Pentagon in disgrace what
this war was one of the worst debacles
and
American history does does he understand
that we lost you know and not even to
put it on you know these banal terms of
win or lose but that both Afghanistan
and the world lost exactly I mean does
hundreds of thousands of people lost
their lives an entire area of the world
was destabilized does he have any sense
of that or is he you know no actually
things went you know swimmingly well
well that is indeed the question if
you're asking me and of course you are
asking me I think his capacity to deny
reality has become so great maybe no if
you find the right word maybe we were
victorious in Iraq maybe the world's a
better place I asked him this question
maybe it would be better if we didn't go
there at all
and if you asked me what I believed we
would have been better if we didn't go
there at all this was a nightmare an
unproductive destructive stupid
senseless war and not one that is you
know I mean the effects are far from
over or even being concluded at this
point ongoing war excuse me I misspoke
you know there was one moment it seemed
almost like a flicker of doubt or if not
doubt something in Rumsfeld you at one
point he did say and I think it was
after he tendered his resignation twice
before it was accepted and I think the
second time was after the revelations of
Abu Ghraib which is a subject of where
that happened or how that happened the
torture and abuse of prisoners in your
documentary standard operating procedure
but at one point Rumsfeld said yeah you
know it would have been better if his
resignation had been accepted does you
know I I mean did that surprise you that
at some point he would acknowledge that
yeah maybe it would have been better if
he had been cashiered a couple
earlier he says it in such a strange but
characteristic way he says that maybe it
would have been better if he had left
that given that he's Secretary of
Defense in some sense he's responsible
for what happened at Abu Ghraib even
though he really didn't cause any of
that to happen right so he takes
responsibility and he takes no
responsibility I know of course even
though he may deny it the the enhanced
interrogation techniques that he
approved at Guantanamo migrated to
Afghanistan and Iraq we used to justify
horrendous abuse the soldiers at Abu
Ghraib day one arriving at the prison
saw nudity hooding stress position
standing for long periods of time all
things that were specifically authorized
by Rumsfeld in the haines memo that he
endorsed who's kidding who
I think he's kidding himself what do you
do as a society you know both you know
as a country but then also what do you
do you know in a larger setting as a
citizen of the world with this type of
thing in in the fog of war at one point
McNamara grants that if if America was
defeated in a way he would be considered
a war criminal obviously Rumsfeld does
not think that way but how do we you
know what what is the way to try to
grapple with the enormity of the sense
of delusion that is going on in you know
that you witness it Rumsfeld and it you
know in a large way in the American
government for you know the better part
of the 21st century it's scary because
I'm an American I love this country I
like to think that our democracy works
after a fashion
that the people in power are thoughtful
responsible rational but that doesn't
seem to be the case in this story seems
to be otherwise if not the opposite
so Rumsfeld Rumsfeld is gone Rumsfeld
left even before George Bush was ended
his presidency but you know in since
then we've had a continuation and many
people on the left and on the right
talked about this under Obama we had
essentially a continuation of the war
policies of George W Bush he tripled
troop strength in Afghanistan and still
pretends that his Afghan surge was a big
turning point
he followed Bush's exit plan from Iraq
and had his then Secretary of Defense
Leon Panetta work overtime to try and
extend troop stays in both Iraq and
Afghanistan generally unsuccessfully
also since you know over the past year
or so basically because of Edward
Snowden and a few other NSA leakers
we've learned that there you know there
is massive expanded surveillance going
on under Obama so that he's not only
continued many Bush era policies that
are you know extremely disturbing to say
the least but actually expanded them he
has a presidential kill list the New
York Times reported where he doesn't
report to anybody why somebody's on it
and if he can take them out or not do
you feel comfortable even with rummy
cashier to now in the you know lost in
the fog of his own delusions is America
in better hands now or what you know
what is the way forward to actually try
and pull some accountability to our
leaders to speak honestly openly and
transparently about how they're
governing the country and how they're
waging war in our name do I think it's
better or for worse with Barack Obama as
opposed to george w bush better
many people including myself hoped for
complete and utter transformation and
there wasn't one there was a degree of
continuity with the past I'm one of
those who believes that Barack Obama was
saddled with in a set of impossible
tasks of trying to unwind so many many
many bad policies and a disastrous
economy which he inherited from george w
bush that what he actually can
accomplish is severely constrained
severely limited I'm glad he's in office
I think the country benefits greatly
from his presence I also feel and in
this sense I disagree with the Obama
administration that those figures in the
Bush administration who led us to war
under false pretenses and I don't care
whether they truly believe them or not
to me that's not really relevant they
were false they were false claims and
they should be held accountable for that
fact there seems to be and maybe it's
not a modern tendency maybe it's a
tendency through history just to sweep
the past under the rug and pretend it's
not there anymore or
lifting up the acetate window on a magic
slate and it all vanishes I think that's
a bad thing not a good thing I think we
benefit I truly believe we benefit by
confronting our past in the hope that we
can maybe not a learn a lot about it or
from it but learn something rather
nothing I have my own version of the
santiana quote my more despairing
version santiana said those unfamiliar
with history are condemned to repeat it
I say those unfamiliar with history are
condemned to repeat it without a sense
of ironic futility well speaking of
discovering the past perhaps and and
this larger question of evidence in the
world because you know your films and
the thin blue line is the is the movie
that brought you to a very wide audience
first and that was about the
reconstruction of events you know where
a man's life held was held in the
balance a person accused of murder
who was on death row you your film
intervened in talking about the evidence
in that case to such a degree that the
person was ultimately freed in a
wilderness of error your book from a
couple of years ago you talked about the
Jeffrey McDonald case which became known
as the fatal vision case of a green
beret doctor who was ultimately found
guilty of murdering his his pregnant
wife and their other children after
claiming a bunch of hippies had run in
it was made famous in a book by Joe
McGinnis who along with Janet Malcolm
and other journalists became the really
the villains of your book which is a
fascinating deconstruction of false
categories that are kind of used whether
it's psych being a psychopath or
forensic evidence that are used to
convict people do you think we're in a
particular era where evidence is held in
absolutely low regard or is this just
simply the human condition
[ __ ] well let's not forget that we as
humans have created a vast amount of
real knowledge we have been successful
not always successful but often
successful at drawing a line between
false belief and knowledge between fact
and fiction between truth and untruth if
we have any claim to nobility I think it
comes from that does that mean that
there are no longer problems that people
are capable of believing preposterous
things that our capacity to believe our
are inherent credulity about things puts
us at enormous risk it does I have had a
career recording all kinds of stories
over the years stories about how people
prefer untruth to the truth stories
about people who are blinded by their
own spurious convictions stories about
false ideas but in all of that I have an
unshakable belief in the truth maybe we
can't always find it maybe we can't
always know it but in principle we can
find it and we can know it and that's
our goal in in a wilderness of error you
seemed in your treatment of journalists
in particular of McGinnis and Janet
Malcolm of The New Yorker and McGinnis
of course recently died which I believe
means that he can no longer be libeled
that I'll just throw that out there but
you you suggest strongly that he
actually changed the narrow you
encouraging me to speak ill of the dead
here yes I suppose I am
or I speak honestly of the dead
you you imply strongly if not outright
state that McGinnis changed his
narrative arc because that would be
better for his book that his publisher
was pressuring him to and this was
before McDonald was found guilty to play
the line that McDonald was actually
guilty when evidence was not as
clear-cut so that's one type of
motivation to believe a falsehood or to
spread a falsehood with Janet Malcolm in
her book about Jeffrey MacDonald in the
treatment you take great issue with Diu
she seems to be much more interested in
just telling stories and that the
internal logic of a story of a tragedy
or a comedy is more important that it's
actual correspondence to events that
might have happened
is it worth drawing a distinction in in
these competing reasons for why people
tell untruth or is it just more
important to recognize that truth is out
there and we should be seeking it and we
should be acting in good faith both
there zillion reasons why people believe
things that aren't so I suppose I could
create a taxonomy of false belief this
falls into that category and that falls
into some other category and on and on
and on and on what disturbed me most
about fatal vision Joe McGinnis account
of the Macdonald case is that he knew
better he represented evidence in one
way on one occasion and represented it
in the opposite way on another that fact
alone troubles me if McGinnis committed
a crime now in Janet Malcolm's world the
crime was that he wasn't entirely honest
with McDonald and then she goes into
this whole deal about how all
journalists betray their subject
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
I'll make several points really really
quickly because I just don't want to
belabor this at the moment this is not
about journalists in their subjects in
any human interaction I don't care what
it is
people with whole things people
misrepresent what they're thinking
people lie to other people people
deceive other people and in some
instances people are kind to other
people and loving to other people
there's a whole world of human
relationships out there
McDonald's mcginnises crime - McDonald
was not that he didn't tell McDonald hey
I think you're a cold-blooded murderer
but I'm going to pretend you're a really
nice guy and I'm going to write a book
that's going to exonerate you well
that's not nice that's really really
pretty crummy its kind of Iago like
two-faced but that's not the crime the
crime is ignored the facts and pretended
they were different from what they were
and then Janet Malcolm comes along and
tells you that facts may not matter this
is an alternative universe to the one I
want to live in I'm sorry
facts do matter there is a fact of the
matter in that house on Military
Reservation in Fayetteville North
Carolina Fort Bragg in that house where
Geoffrey McDonald lived with his wife
and two baby daughters there's a fact of
the matter he either killed him or he
didn't and in principle we should be
able to find out whether it's a or B and
if we can't we have to ask ourselves why
not there's a real world out there the
thin blue line a car was traveling down
a deserted road in West Dallas then turn
on their headlights cops are at a Burger
King they see the car go by a routine
traffic stop one of the police officers
the female police officer stays in the
car the other gets out and is shot to
death
well someone pull the trigger
someone had his hand on the gun and
pulled the trigger
cops got it wrong and it could be proved
that they got it wrong they fingered the
wrong guy our job our job is to figure
out whether a WMD in Iraq yes or no not
the unknown unknown and some excursion
into fanciful epistemology our job is to
separate fact from fiction
my job in the Jeffrey McDonald case
Janet Malcolm may say that she didn't
care to look at all the folders of
evidence my job is to deal with the
evidence in a way it's my only job
that's my job the job is evidence the
job is thinking the job is ratiocination
the job is separating truth from untruth
okay
McGinnis was very naughty he didn't
treat McDonald very nicely he
he was a bad guy for that reason alone
but that's not the crime and there's a
crime here a war crime in the case of
Donald Rumsfeld the crime is the
gobbledygook the blizzard of words the
misdirections the evasions and even
worse than that the lack of thinking and
ultimately at the heart of all of it at
the bottom of all of it is the disregard
and the devaluation of evidence because
guess what it's all we have the movie
the documentary is dedicated to Roger
Ebert can you explain why and then in
can you explain why and then also hazard
a opinion is this a good time to be a
documentarian sure in the sense of well
explain a little bit about your
connection with Roger Ebert and also you
know why it's a good time to be a
documentary no filmmaker ever had a
better friend than Roger Ebert he was in
an extraordinary good guy and a friend
to me and someone will be missed his
missed I made my first film gates of
heaven years and years ago now he was
shown at the New York Film Festival in
1978 and there was a newspaper strike
going on so no one wrote about the movie
it was almost as if the movie had never
been made and then out of nowhere really
unexpectedly to Chicago critics started
writing about gates of heaven they were
on television Gene Siskel and Roger
Ebert they did one show they did another
show they did a third show and they did
a fourth show they wrote about it in
their respective newspapers the
sun-times
The Tribune in Chicago they became
champions of me my work that movie in
particular I've often said to Roger
Ebert no Roger no film career my only
problem with Roger was he loved gates of
heaven so much he put it on his list of
the 10 best films ever made that every
time I made a movie and I showed it to
him I would say how much less are you
going to like this one two gates in
heaven
can I ask you did not simply admire him
though because he gave you a hand up in
your career was instrumental I mean is
there is there a lesson to be learned
one of the things that Ebert did it
seems to me is that he democratized film
criticism he both took it seriously and
he made it accessible to a wide variety
of people who might not have thought
critically about film is there a
parallel at your work because I mean
this is one of the reasons I asked is it
a good time to be a documentarian in a
way it seems realities more up for grabs
than ever because more people can
represent their perspectives on truth
and you know it's almost like a real
world Rashomon effect but by the same
token we can get a clearer sense of
what's really out there by kind of
sifting through competing points of view
and also recognizing that were in
computer we're in conversation with
people and we should try to reach some
kind of overlapping agreement if not
unanimity at least some kind of rough
consensus as to what reality is as to
what quality is as to what's important
and what's not so important you're
seeing a number of contradictory things
though because reality is not about an
agreement between people you know I can
decide that the earth is flat with as
many people as I choose to bring into
the argument without really affecting
the underlying reality that the earth in
fact is not flat it's round or spherical
or blade spheroid or however you want to
describe it
it's odd Rumsfeld
tells us that Pearl Harbor was a failure
of the imagination we hadn't imagined
Pearl Harbor an advance of Pearl Harbor
what's interesting is that even at the
time of Pearl Harbor we had a glut of
information right we had enormous
amounts of data radar had just come into
existence
there were radar operators aware of the
presence of something strange the
problem is as the amount of data that we
have available to us increases and
increases and increases does it bring us
closer to the truth or does it create an
even deeper kind of model and I would
have to say the honest answer is I'm not
sure does seem that the I mean if you
think about a movie like Fruitvale
station which was nominated for some
Academy Awards or talked about in that
way anyway you know that's about a story
where the police you know killed a kid
and they told one authoritative tale
which was then debunked by essentially
disbursed information gathering in the
form of cell phone footage by people who
witnessed it so I mean it does seem like
where the documentary ins dilemma may be
that because more people can tell their
story because of Technology because of
changes in things like that we can get
more company can get more multiple
perspectives but they should be focused
on figuring out what actually happened
as opposed to saying okay well here's a
truth that I want to live in without
having to justify I think there are
multiple truth is one and we should go
in search of it and you answer you ask
better time for documentary filmmakers
of course 30 years ago when I made my
first documentary film there was no end
and cinema in this country no
distributor is no theaters that's all
changed why what continuity in your work
and burner Hertzog Hertzog has many
movies that are about people who choose
to live in a world of their own making
that typically leads to disastrous
results are you kind of doing the
documentary documentarians version of
many of his of his his project well I
have been incredibly influenced by
Verner over the years when people ask me
about my documentaries I remind them
well what tradition did I come out of
what were the documentaries that I saw
as a young man at the Pacific Film
Archive in Berkeley California was a
direct cinema cinema verite what was it
and often it was expressionistic
documentaries first and foremost among
them with many of the early works of
Verner Herzog these are films that I
loved then I still love and have been
incredibly influential on what I do we
remain friends I mean he is still a
close friend well we'll leave it there I
want to thank Errol Morris the director
of the unknown known for talking to
recent TV about Donald Rumsfeld about
documentary film and much much more
Thank You Errol thank you for reason TV
I'm Nick Gillespie